what's the biggest audition you've ever
had Wow the biggest audition I've ever
had a good question
and I would say the October sky audition
I had was you went from the cast
director and the director and then I got
the screen test which the screen test is
always interesting because they put you
up in the clothes and the outfits and
actually film you doing this theme he's
got two other actors that are hoping to
get the same part and they come up and
they dress them up you know identical to
you and you get rid of the clothes and I
ended up getting the movie and then it
worked out and then you think about the
other two guys that showed up on set and
went through the whole rigmarole you got
a sign and paperwork and everything it
doesn't happen so you definitely feel
the stakes you know are pretty high and
then in the interesting sort of audition
story that I tell a lot again something
I learned when The Fast and the Furious
audition came my way again where I was
at in my time at that time in my life I
didn't realize what I had I was off in
my own sort of thinking about what I
thought about the business I got the
audition and it was called red line
actually at the time and I I remember
passing on the audition and why because
I just didn't wanna I had in my mind I
wanted to do something completely
different with my life at the time again
maybe 23 years old you know so I got the
audition
I passed got the audition twice I passed
right my agent at the time calls me up
and says what are you doing like you
really want to pass on this and I said
yeah I mean I was just being a little
punk just like fine hung up the phone on
me I'm like yeah right I'm mom making
decision decision another agent for the
same agency called me up and he said
you know come on go in go in and I'm
like okay I'll go in I was being a brat
I was being a brat and I way my audition
and I met the director Rob Cohen he's
very friendly and so nice and the
caching director who I love him and so I
auditioned them and they liked what I
did and they called me back or they want
me to come back and read with a couple
of the other actors and so I'm like and
then you start to like to reply your
mind like oh oh you like me okay you
know all right yeah yeah I'll go back
yeah sure so I go in and I read with sub
when he was Matt Schulze at the time and
I'm Johnny strong I believe and they
were trying to stick like the guys that
you know because they already had you
know Paul and VIN and everybody and I
ended up booking this movie I got the
part and and I'm like wow this is really
cool and we're going to do all these
cars and then we got on set and it
became you know this crazy thing and
everyone's going to be like oh it's
going to be it's going to be huge it's
gonna be this big moving I'm like no I
just don't I don't I don't think so guys
I was just so locked into this into this
brain of mine and then lo and behold it
became like a huge phenomenon it changed
my life instantly and it taught me again
that you would never never never no
don't don't turn down an audition don't
don't be silly you know and I was really
silly and I tell the story and not that
I was so appreciative that I went in and
I was given that opportunity and I've
got it changed my life forever forever
so um I learned a valuable lesson than
you know just you know keep your mind
open you know appreciate what you have
if it comes when you're 19 if it comes
when you're 40 appreciate that moment
what were you hoping for at 23 what what
type of role would you've thought was
more well I mean I realize a lot of
actors they're not maybe at that time
and then they see what it is later but
what were you hope will kind of
I guess at that time I wanted to do
something edgy and hardcore heart is my
luck's or something yeah I just wanted
to do something just you know I didn't I
you know maybe it was again it was the
computer geek you know it was like
computer geek Jesse yeah you know and it
was like in my mind maybe I was sort of
like pushing away those characters
because I would just keep getting
computer guy computer this computer this
and it drove me crazy you know for maybe
that also played a part in it I would
just be like pushing that away but no
I'm not that guy I want to do something
crazy and swear and and be a crazy weird
guy and you know when it again when it's
your part it's a very personal thing and
it will find you it will find you and
I'm so lucky that it did because again
that movie has now become you know
they're working on number eight and it's
like you know again people recognize me
from it every day and they tell me how
much that movie means to them and how
many times they've seen it and so I'm
like again I've been very lucky so I
yeah you just never know
did you ever drive your own white Jetta
no and they barely let us drive in the
movie too because you just don't give
actors cars on set we got to drive a
little bit and then they would put us in
uh picture cars which was great and the
scene where I'm racing Johnny Tran they
they had tied up my car it was a picture
car they tied it up to a semi and they
hauled him like a 70 80 miles per hour
in the mid put an actual car my eye line
racing next to me so when I'm driving
like this is you actually like racing
somebody not for real but you know
they're in complete control
obviously the cameras are on the
the you know the better the truck and
whatnot so but yeah and I'm looking back
man I mean so cool just you know I wish
to do I want to do something like that
now and have the sort of the greater
appreciation and the the majestical
scope that I have now about this
business and what it means I think that
would be a huge thrill you know to go
back and sort of do something like that
has such a again again you just never
know the movies that you think are going
to be huge
no not so much in the movies you think
that I don't know it turned out to be
phenomenal
so yeah well it's the beauty of being 23
is that you don't sometimes realize what
what's being given you know I think
right there's a beauty to that - yeah
absolutely and I had no idea and it
taught me a lot you know so going back
to October Sky where were you in your
life when you have that audition for was
your mantra I was a barely 21 years old
I had just turned 21 uh-huh I was in
sort of the same mindset I remember
being on set and thinking I don't know
that anyone and that was my read that
was I don't even know it and I love this
interview because it makes me reflect
and makes me go back and sort of re
appreciate you know the things that I've
gone through and been through and and
that has worked out you know it's scary
to think what if it didn't work out
where would I be
what would I be doing so I was a fresh
21 and you know I'm now I'm on set with
with all these picture cards and it was
in his time period you know were telling
the true story about Homer Hickam and
the Rocket Boys and Jake Gyllenhaal was
he was 16 I think at the time he was
being still he had to do school onset
you know and we'll be Scott and I were
the two oldest and and again we had the
the only thing to do and Tennessee was
the
yes 24-hour Walmart it's this and that's
how we catch ourselves busy and you know
I remember the studio is sending us
Playstations you know when we first got
the part and what like these kids like
oh you're studying is like Playstations
and like all of a sudden you're just
being thrown all these opportunities and
it's it's again when you when you're
young and you don't realize it but that
was another greatest times ever when I
most-pure just you know when you're that
age to you're not really thinking about
all your dope stuff to ask to come into
play you know that we worry about much
later on we're just free and I had fun
so you know and we just had they did it
they just did a rock boys festival that
I just attended not too long ago for his
anniversary I guess stick to 15 years 15
years no like that was fast mysterious
probably longer
I don't know now that all these
anniversaries it just reminds me about
how much I've been in this industry but
ah but yeah it's cool to see where all
these projects go and what to become
you